[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous retrouver dans le
7-8 loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
dans le département et tout de suite le
sommaire de ce numéro nous plongerons
dans les profondeurs de l'océan aux
clayes-sous-bois l'artiste louzoun nous
fait vivre une expérience visuelle et
sensorielle jusqu'au 14 mai donc nous
accueillerons chantal van treeck
organisatrice du festival de courts
métrages de rambouillet jusqu'au 12 mai
vous pouvez participer pour créer la
fiche de cette nouvelle édition nous en
parlerons plus en détail comment ça va
sur la terre réponse à cette question
dans le spectacle musical proposé samedi
29 avril à la ferme de bel ébat mélanie
poker nous en dira plus dans notre
rendez-vous junior et ce lundi 1er mai
le musée rend beau livre à enghien
organise une bourse de jouets anciens et
différentes animations des spécialistes
seront là pour conseiller les amateurs
sur leurs achats des pièces détachées
seront en vente pour compléter les
modèles des propriétaires et pour les
enfants bien sûr la possibilité
d'embarquer à bord d'un train à vapeur
on écoute la directrice du musée
propos recueillis par mélanie poker on
aura de réseau un réseau plus récents on
va dire avec les trains qui plaisent aux
enfants puisque de sion gênera gaga
eminem secouru les emblèmes coca cola et
qu'ils peuvent conduire avec une
télécommande
donc là qui est plus maquettes et cette
année on a le cfe qui le cercle
ferroviaire européen qui une association
de préservation du train joints anciens
qui va venir installer un réseau qui va
faire quand même six mètres sur 2 mètres
50 et qui va fonctionner donc on aura
ces réseaux aussi pour les enfants dans
la salle pendant que les parents
pourront regarder les stands et
éventuellement acheter
à ne pas manquer la semaine prochaine la
toute première édition du jumping
international du château de versailles
les meilleurs cavaliers du monde
s'affronteront du 5 au 7 mai lors de ce
concours de saut d'obstacles et pour
accueillir l'événement un cadre aussi
magique que prestigieux la grande écurie
du roi jean maurice bonneau
organisateurs de l'événement nous en dit
plus au micro de michael et demi d'euros
ici ce sera la piste avec les tribunes
là-bas derrière et on aura une épreuve
de la journée
et puis des nocturnes avec les plus
grosses épreuves avec les plus gros
enjeu et pour se terminer le dimanche
après midi et avec le grand prix rolex
et puis la particularité c'est aussi que
le public aura accès avec son ticket
d'entrée
bien sûr au sport mais aussi à la
galerie des carrosses aux grandes
écuries de l'académie et on va parler
cinéma à présent le festival de cannes
débute bientôt mais dans les yvelines
aussi le septième art est à l'honneur le
festival du court métrage de rambouillet
revient fin juin pour une sixième
édition et il est encore temps de
déposer votre film ou de proposer une
affiche avec nous chantal van tricot
fondatrice de l'événement bonjour
chantal bonjour câline alors on le
disait alors se voir mais merci à vous
de venir et je le disais à l'instant
chacun peut proposer une affiche pour
illustrer cette nouvelle édition un
concours jusqu'au 12 mai voilà ce que
c'est tout à fait c'est un concours pour
donc réalisé la fiche du festival qu'on
organise depuis le début c'était une
idée qu'avait isabelle je crois qui est
une des fondatrices
du festival est alors dont il s'agit de
faire un dessin
nos choix ce que vous voulez pour
illustrer le court métrage est donc
c'est sur une feuille format a3 ou a4
on peut le faire en conception numérique
ou sur papier et je crois que vous allez
donner après l'adresse où il faut
envoyer tout ça mais donc c'est bientôt
il faut vous dépêcher prendre vos
crayons vos stylos vos palettes et
préparer ce concours qui fonctionne bien
en général et puis alors après donc la
fiche sera présenté dans tout
rambouillet et ses environs bien
évidemment et le gagnant assistera aux
trois jours du festival fera partie du
jury et regagnera aussi des places de
cinéma donc ça vaut vraiment le coup
donc du coup alors vous le désir c'est
vraiment libre en fait il n'y a pas de
thème précis il n'y a pas de voix lasse
il faut que ça parle de signe enfin ça
évoque le cinéma
le court métrage d'animation ce que on
aura aussi bien des films de fiction que
d'animation voilà c'est le cinéma
l'animation la commune qu'il faut se
dépêcher d'envoyer en tout cas de ses
créations alors l'adresse c'est sophie @
ça tourne point fr je pense qu'on va
faire de toute façon à part être un
petit peu au cours de l'émission et pour
envoyer son fils par contre on a un peu
plus de temps alors là c'est jusqu'au 29
mai pour participer à ce festival court
dans la forêt alors à qui s'adresse
professionnels amateurs qui veut qui a
envie qui a fait un court métrage les
professionnels ils ont un petit peu
dépassé ce stade là peut-être parce que
c'est vrai que dans ce métier on
commence souvent par le court métrage et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
c'est plus compliqué souvent de faire un
court métrage qu'un long métrage enfin
vous qui avez une école de vie c'est
comme écrire un texte très court pour
raconter une histoire c'est plus
compliqué que de développer c'est un peu
le problème du court métrage parce que
ça doit être forcément moins de 52
minutes moins d'une heure là nous on a
des contraintes particulières donc ces
25 minutes et la thématique aussi à
partir du moment où c'est une fiction
un film d'animation est libre on peut
envoyer donc là aussi directement par
par internet
son film et on a jusqu'au 29 mai pour
pour faire ça et alors donc il y aura
des prix oui justement lors c'est un
festival il ya un jury de toile et
composer le jury quels sont les prix
c'est une très très bonne question à
laquelle je ne vous répondrai pas parce
qu'on n'a pas encore notre président du
jury
mais c'est vrai qu'on a toujours eu des
gens de cinéma bien évidemment
producteurs technicien monteur
réalisateur acteur alors on a eu des
très beaux des très beaux enfin des très
connus j'allais dire présidents de
grandes personnalités jean rochefort qui
est aussi du coin donc bon voilà on
connaît on a eu marie-anne chazel qui
est venu très gentiment pour ça il ya eu
victor lanoux
il y avait aussi gérard rinaldi qui est
venue des charlots et puis plus
récemment c'était frédéric gorny qui est
notamment l'acteur deux avocats et
associés une série qui a bien marché à
la télé et qui voilà qui préside le jury
donc vraiment des personnalités de
l'audiovisuel enfin oui vraiment oui
alors se rappeler leur vote la
cofondatrice de ce festival pourquoi
avoir voulu le créer alors il se trouve
que on avait enfin j'étais chargé de du
comité des fêtes de poids ni la forêt
qui est à 7 kilomètres de rambouillet et
on s'était dit on avait une belle salle
des fêtes et on s'est dit tiens pourquoi
on ferait pas
une projection de courts métrages
sachant qu'on avait aussi à poigne et
isabelle breivik qui est dans le cinéma
qui a une société de distribution qui
s'appelle distrib films et qui
franchement avec toutes les facilités
pour avoir faire cet appel à court
métrage et voilà donc la première année
on l'a fait à poigny la forêt mais
problème c'est qu'une salle de
spectacles de enfin une salle
polyvalente
en plus c'est pas une salle de cinéma on
n'a pas l'acoustique on n'a pas à la
qualité d'image est très gentiment mais
clair le lieu que du cinéma vox de
rambouillet nous a dit attendez faisons
ça à rambouillet donc dès l'année
suivante la deuxième année on a fait le
festival à rambouillet et c'est vrai
qu'elle dans une salle de cinéma c'est
c'est formidable quoi donc c'est à fait
indiquée ouais bon ben c'est à noter en
tout cas les visiteurs sont attendus dès
le 30 juin au cinéma vox de rambouillet
merci en tout cas chantal vente reid est
revenue sur notre plateau on le rappelle
vous avez jusqu'au 12 mai pour
participer au concours de l'affiché et
jusqu'au 29 pour envoyer votre film le
festival qui se déroulera du 30 juin au
2 juillet merci beaucoup chantal merci
gamine et aux clayes-sous-bois l'artiste
plasticien blues où nous emmène dans les
profondeurs de l'océan loin de l'image
idyllique que l'on pourrait s'en faire
le visiteur découvre un monde malmené
par l'activité de l'homme
une exposition qui mêle lumière son et
recyclage imaginiez nicolas landry
oh
dirigez l'insaisissable avec ses
installations l'artiste loose ou conduit
la lumière pour nous plonger dans les
fonds marins
en fait j'ai imaginé une représentation
d'un fonds marins agressé muté torturé
par l'activité la nôtre par nos
activités industrielles et nos déchets
c'est pour ça qu'on a un test d'oursins
donc une coquille pour 5 et géante la
bac et tout en plastique tout ça
présente la gélification des océans la
plastification des océans et la
transformation de tous les organismes
marins par le plastique il engage un
maximum ils en sont tous pleins et puis
du coup n'ont en revanche pas aussi une
réflexion écologique porté par ses
créations en matériaux recyclés canettes
bois ou bouteilles plastiques des
matières choisies mais qui ne se laisse
pas facilement apprivoiser
j'aime bien le métal ouais le métal
parce que il est capricieux mais il
renvoie bien la lumière c'est que c'est
la matière guidé le métal il me guide
bien quand je le travaille je suis pas
forcément maîtres de la matière elle
m'emmène aussi faire son chemin et avec
la lumière ça marche vraiment bien
grâce à son expérience d'éclairagiste
loose ou a créé son exposition comme une
oeuvre globale une bande-son accompagne
le visiteur
[Musique]
j'ai utilisé des fréquences qu'on
appelle des fréquences solfé jo les
fréquences solfège aux sons des
fréquences qui sont particulières bien
précise et qui agissent sur le corps et
l'esprit
c'est à dire que ces fréquences si on
les écoute des durées et d intensité
suffisante
elles sont capables de nous réparer
l'adn de nous nettoyer le subconscient
de remettre en état nos énergies
une expérience sensorielle et visuels
pour relier l'homme à son environnement
[Musique]
cette semaine pour notre rendez-vous
junior et si nous intéressions à la
terre avec un t majuscule mélanie un
spectacle est à découvrir ce week-end à
guyancourt et ça parle notre belle
planète bleue
c'est ça c'est un rendez-vous qui porte
bien son monde c'est comment ça va sur
la terre c'est un spectacle musical et
végéta de produit par la compagnie pavé
volubile c'est une fantaisie à trois
voix et musiciens musiciennes plus
précisément un accordéon un vibraphone
et des percussions comment ça va sur la
terre c'est aussi le titre d'un texte de
jean tardieu un poète du 20e siècle
on a eu envie de parler de la nature de
pouvoir un petit peu aussi parlé de
l'écologie sans être didactique en fête
en musique de manière assez légères et
de pouvoir amener les enfants à ce
qu'ils aient une
un intérêt par exemple à aller chercher
dans une touffe d'herbe qu'est ce qu'on
y trouve
comment ça fonctionne tout ce qu'on voit
pas mais en fait qui se passe qui se
passe autour et qui fonctionne et qu'il
faut pas abîmer alors on l'aura bien
compris les questions d'écologie et
d'environnement
et tout ça en chansons avec des textes
originaux c'est écrit par michel buret
et d'autres inspirés par jean tardieu
comme j'ai dit plus haut mais aussi
robert desnos ermont queneau alors c'est
un voyage poétique à découvrir dès l'âge
de 5 ans et qui fait appel à
l'imagination des enfants par exemple
les xhosas on a entendu tout à l'heure
devient tour à tour un ver de terre un
nuage et centre d'accessoires regarder
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
merci mélanie nous avoir présenté ce
spectacle musical comment ça va sur la
terre est à découvrir ce samedi 29 avril
à 11 heures à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et on passe maintenant à
notre agenda avec deux rendez vous à
noter pour les sportifs ce week-end là
jean racine investi la haute vallée de
chevreuse deux jours consacrée au vélo
des animations et des randonnées tous
niveaux sont proposés rendez vous au
village départ situé au domaine saint
paul de saint rémy les chevreuse pour en
profiter et si vous êtes un passionné de
rugby en 32e de finale de fédérale 3
plaisir recevra l'équipe de pontault
combault ce dimanche au stade robert
barran un match déterminant dans la
course à la montée en fédérale 2
objectifs fixés par les plaisirs wa
début de la rencontre à 15 heures et
c'est la fin de cette loi zir merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]
oh